6 26 on your monday morning what's
driving you crazy some lane restrictions
on the south end of the 15
as well as on the 95 near the spaghetti
bowl
let's start on the south end of the i-15
from blue diamond road getting onto the
freeway is going to be tough for the
next few nights
specifically nevada department of
transportation says the ramps to the
northbound 15
from both eastbound and westbound blue
diamond will be restricted now this
works actually started last night
it will run from 9 p.m until 5 each
following morning until thursday
ndot says they have surveying crews that
need some of those lanes
let's scoot up now to the 95 just east
of the spaghetti bowl
this also starting tonight at nine and
running until four the following morning
also through thursday morning
the northbound side of the 95 515 you're
going to lose a couple of lanes between
eastern and las vegas boulevard
ndot says those lines are going to be
closed for bridge inspections
and speaking of that we hope you've
taken a moment to check out the ndot
website
for public input on that proposed
downtown access project to update the
freeway there it's called
n.d.a.p.com don't worry about writing
that down because all of this info is on
our website 8newsnow.com you just click
traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me with traffic with pictures and
video to traffic eight at eight news now
dot com